lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
practicar encontrar patrones en
secuencias de números patrones que nos
lleven de un número a otro en estos
números magenta lo que yo quiero
encontrar es cómo llego del 4 al 25 y si
es lo mismo que tengo que hacer para
llegar del 25 al 46 del 46 al 67 y
continuar y continuar y continuar y por
ejemplo cómo le hago para llegar del 4
al 25 y observó que el 25 pues no es un
múltiplo de 4 pero qué tal si sumo al 4
21 o sea es decir el 21 4
tengo 25 y si yo a 25 le sumó 21
voy a obtener 46 y parece que sí que el
patrón es sumar 21 a ver continuamos del
46 más 21
pues tengo el 67
y efectivamente este es el patrón o sea
que yo podría seguir obteniendo otros
números de esta secuencia
simplemente sumando 21 por ejemplo si 67
le sumó 21 voy a obtener el 88 y si a 88
le sumó 21 voy a obtener un obtengo 109
muy bien y así podría continuar y
continuar y continuar entonces aquí lo
que hicimos fue sumar 21 y para llegar
de aquí a acá lo que hicimos fue sumar
ahora vamos con los números que están en
verde entonces tengo el 3 y del 3 sigue
el 6 y bueno a primera vista puedo decir
que si sumo tres
llegó de 33 es 6 muy bien y ahora en par
del 6 al 12
muy bien pues 6 más 3 pues no no es 12
tendría yo que sumar 6 y después del 12
al 24 pues tampoco es 6 ni 3
entonces para llegar del 12 al 24 yo
tendría que sumar 12 entonces no es 3
pero lo que sí puedo observar es que
cada uno de los que estoy sumando es el
doble de la anterior y entonces
podríamos esto
escribirlo a ver dm vamos a simplificar
esto pues si es el doble vamos a quitar
esto perfecto entonces para llegar de 3
al 6 como dijimos es el doble entonces
por dos que eso es el doble llegó a 63
por 12-6 y ahora
por 2
efectivamente 6 por 2 es 12 y ahora 12
pues perfecto está funcionando es 24 muy
bien
así que en este caso la secuencia la
obtuvimos multiplicando por un cierto
número a cada uno de los números para
obtener el siguiente en este caso fue el
23 por 12 6 6 por 12 12 12 por 2 es 24
muy bien ahora vamos con la última línea
de números en ella aparece el 3 y luego
el 6 acá que muy bien es lo mismo que
tengo aquí arriba entonces yo podría
otra vez multiplicar 3 por 2 para llegar
al 6
pero luego el que viene es el 9 el
siguiente es el 9 y ese no se obtiene
multiplicando 6 por 2
y del 9 sigue el 12 y tampoco parece que
funciona esta idea
lo que sí parece funcionar es que si yo
sumo 3 al 3 obtengo 6 muy bien y si a 6
le sumó 3 obtengo 9 muy bien y si a 9 le
sumó 3 obtengo el 12 perfecto lo hemos
identificado en este caso para obtener
el siguiente número de la secuencia lo
que tengo que hacer es sumar 3 cada uno
de ellos se obtiene sumando 3 y parece
que lo hemos resuelto el punto aquí es
encontrar algo que puedo aplicarle a
cada uno de los números que me lleve de
uno a otro y eso mismo me lleve al
siguiente y pueda continuar y continuar
y continuar y tenemos que asegurarnos
que eso que encontramos funciona para ir
del primer número al segundo número y
del segundo número al tercero
tercero al cuarto y así continuar en
toda la secuencia como hicimos en estas
secuencias en la primera lo que hicimos
fue sumar 21 cada vez en la segunda lo
que hicimos fue multiplicar por 2 cada
vez y en la tercera lo que hicimos fue
sumar 3 cada vez